hi I'm Kevin girdert and these are my
favorite traps from the soft films
hello everyone it's time to play a game
oh what are you doing
I really love the bathroom trap from saw
one where we first meet luanelle's
character Adam and carry out with his
character Dr Gordon in the course of
this uh of this story We Go From the two
waking up and realizing that they're
trapped to Carrie's character being in
the state of mind that he can actually
cut off his own foot in order to escape
and uh we do a little bit more shorthand
now with um with saw films where they go
from learning about their situation to
you know cutting off a limb sometimes in
just a minute or two so uh uh I think
James was rightly cautious enough to
make sure that we invested the time to
make sure that we believe that Kerry
could actually do this but um really
that bathroom was where my career as an
editor and a director began because from
the day first day that we started
editing that film I said we're on to
something really special here so in in a
way that's my favorite when we edited
the the film originally we started get
into the flashbacks much earlier in the
movie but we found that the audience was
really enjoying the fact that there were
these two guys stuck in a dirty bathroom
and it was kind of cool that they were
in such a claustrophobic environment so
we we rethought the structure of the
film quite a bit so that uh we don't go
into those flashbacks until about 15
minutes into the into the movie when um
when Carrie says he doesn't want us to
cut through our chains he wants us to
cut through our feet uh so I think I
think that's where we kind of let the
audience breathe and say okay there is
going to be more to this movie than just
these two guys cutting back and forth
between the two of them but uh you know
then once the story gets rolling we
followed more the structure that James
shot
hello all opinion I want to play a game
I really like the Arby's trap the
furnace in saw two uh had a really great
time editing that um I thought Abby was
was such a creepy character and then to
see him put into this this very
claustrophobic environment uh was pretty
neat we got great performances from the
other actors in the scene as their you
know most of these characters are really
despicable people but you still see the
the humanity on their faces as they're
reacting to this guy getting burned
alive Before Their Eyes Darren shot that
amazing shot with a hand slaps up
against the glass I had I had a little
bit of um inspiration just as the editor
of that film uh we it didn't quite make
sense or it wasn't quite clear in the
way that the jigsaw tape was originally
written uh what Abby had to do to get
out of this uh trap so we came up with
the idea of uh of the little picture of
the devil inside and in the tape John
cryptically says once you are in hell
only the devil can help you out then as
he's starting to burn he sees the little
cartoon of the Devil in a handle and
then it lets him know that he has to
reach through the Flames to uh to turn
that handle if he has any chance of
surviving but it's a Saw movie so of
course he dies
wow
people would think I'm crazy if I don't
include the needle pit from saw two in
my list of favorite traps you know that
was another one where uh we we liked it
and we thought the performances were
really good but the very first cut was
not working uh at least for us that
we're in the editing room and it's
because those those syringes are
actually plastic so we wound up like
crushing a bunch of glass and then just
raking through it with a stick and
recording the sound of that and then
substituting that sound into what Johnny
Smith's hands are doing as they as they
move through the needles and as soon as
we did that it was like ah it's the
worst thing I've ever seen it was great
really fun cutting that scene
yeah
what's that
the lawyer from your firm has 20 seconds
to cross this room the steam room in saw
six it's it's a personal favorite I
guess just for um you know selfish
reasons the scene that was originally
written for um William and uh the the
character of his uh of his lawyer that
um that became the steam room we we
couldn't do the scene that was
originally written and uh we
brainstormed a lot what to do and then
finally doing what I usually do on a saw
film is it's you know what sucks what
would be a really bad thing to happen
and somehow I got thinking about Steam
and and William having to endure the
pain of steam burns in order to help uh
uh Carolyn caves character get through
this Maze and it all kind of came
together in my head and I told the uh
Tony ayani the production designer hey
what if we build a giant metal Maze and
uh you know filled with steam and traps
and uh and he was like uh who's gonna
pay for that but you know it all came
together and um uh I love the little
twists at the end that Carolyn thinks
that
um you know she's free but then it turns
out she has to kill William if she's
going to have a chance of taking this
thing off her neck she fails and and
that's that but I I I really admire her
performance it's it's to me one of the
most impassioned in any saw trap
foreign
so the shotgun Carousel from saw six
it's it's my personal favorite uh it was
at that time the hardest thing that I'd
ever shot and uh you know for a long
time it remained the hardest thing I
ever shot I underestimated how hard it
would be to shoot the number of of
camera angles which wound up being over
200 200 unique shots to make this uh
scene come together in the editing room
you need close-ups of these characters
or on a moving platform inside a cake
and so we had to figure out a way to
follow their faces but then when you
think about it every time somebody's
back gets blown out and everyone else is
is splattered with blood uh obviously
you have to stop the camera and you have
to clean things up and redo things and
it just went on and on it went on and on
for days over schedule so uh I I wound
up um not going over schedule in the
movie as a whole in the end but
definitely on that trap I went over by
several days also I'll never forget when
Sean Matheson the actor uh playing the
the last guy to get shot he came up to
me and you know the the word in the
script were what they were but he's and
we'd you know rehearse them as you know
somewhat normal but then he said what if
I do it this way and that's where he he
came up with you spineless whip
[__]
that way and uh you know to me that's
the most iconic moment in in saw six
look at me when you're killing me love
it love it and then when we shoot him in
the back or in the chest in slow motion
and with his sweater explodes with blood
fantastic
oh
hell no
yes
in the saw series I felt like we were
getting a little bit too convoluted and
it was all in service of the need to
keep the John Kramer character in the
story even after he dies at the end of
saw three and so we were getting into
all these flashbacks and uh you know
weird excuses and apprentices and that
sort of thing it it had gotten too
complicated for a general viewer to just
come in and watch one of these films as
a standalone so uh for this it was a
very high priority for me to make it
very simple to understand no matter if
you knew nothing about the saw series at
all but at the same time by including so
much of Tobin and Shawnee and the story
The the fans I I think will love it
because it was a work of love for
everybody involved and you know we made
it for the fans we made it for the
general audience and you know so far the
reactions I've seen indicate that we
succeeded